we're playing with one imposter this
time not two if that imposter wins
we will each send them a thousand
dollars so they'll get 10 grand
oh pressure is on
oh my god i am the imposter 10
000 is on the line one imposter this one
will be interesting
okay i'm gonna do this i could win 10
grand one imposter oh that's so hard
okay that's one that's one
no simon simon find my body i've seen
josh like twice now and both times he's
gone back
simon simon okay i'll move
cello nice nice this is good oh what
yo when'd you get in here bro josh dead
body
there's a body the bottom of the map me
harold were together the whole time we
were indeed did you guys leave each
other at any point in time
even for a second calm down there mister
i was hugging harold the whole time ksi
where'd you come from when you went to
admin
no well i was trying yeah we should we
shoot ksi here can i talk i was with
simon i was sort of
cello when he says he was with me i
walked down into admin for
the last three seconds yeah because i
was doing the card
and thing wait no you weren't you're on
download no no i didn't
think i paid a private investigator to
watch all your videos and take notes of
how you guys act when you're imposter oh
wow
you are joking ksi defensive as imposter
and can fumble with this story
doesn't work well under pressure he's
not very composed your story's breaking
you're getting defensive
not good under pressure you've got to
vote me anyway because it's just
it's it's a meme let's not help the
imposter let's all just skip
i definitely skipped this could have
been the quickest dub
ever whoever is imposter 10 grand
on the line i would hate to be impostor
right now weird thing to say
vic you're faking it bro all right i
can't kill ethan obviously
hmm who am i suss in here i would love
to imposter actually right now
this would be a good chance at 310 grand
be fair if i stick with carl
we cannot die we can it's like kind of
flawed
okay this is good this is good
got a lot of people here i've lost car
my friend carl
oh
no held yes was it you
i can tell you wholeheartedly it wasn't
me mate okay who was in reactor just now
me could have been a vent to reactor
right there's a vent there i'll give it
to whoever's imposter you're doing good
so far where is buddy uh the body's uh
upper engine
i'm just saying ethan was very fast to
vote me off
yeah i wonder i also don't like his
backwards cap
mr chandler chandler when we was running
towards the reactor you went upper
engine no
no i went down harry ran away from it
when the reactor went off he ran away
it's harry bro he's hung out he's
actually not me who are we voting for
vote here and if i'm wrong you can just
vote me up he asked who we voted for you
know
it's him i'm pretty certain how he was
faking toss and electric putting sauce
on josh and harry lots of sauce
everywhere
if they let jj do i'm not paying jj any
money interesting mr carl
sasson josh he was innocent if ethan
dies then that's how i can win
i reckon it's one of those american
dollies what what no i was really killed
okay it's jj
well it wasn't jimmy all right i was
just saying carl keeps talking a lot
but nope it wasn't him who went down
middle when the round started just then
i'm into admin and then back up
i don't know i'm starting harry now that
ethan's dead no simon you can vouch you
saw me do the med bay right
i went into admin did the wires then
went into med bay
and harry was in there who was with him
it came out 100
only the last like 10 seconds i can
vouch for him jimmy why is it not car
because we were together from start to
finish why is no one suss of jj why
look how quiet he is just vote harry for
me and if i'm wrong just vote me off
next round i don't care we know it's not
you
wait where was the body i don't even
know yet it's on top of the trash shoe
in storage
oh he's skipping the vote i'm skipping
we skip here skip here
i'm skipping i'm skipping americans
stick together if anybody goes near us
you're the imposter
oh boy this mr beast on it
is sticking on me for no apparent reason
you know what i haven't got a clue right
now
have i just done lights oh the lights
are up ah
oops sorry boss oh
what why are we still here um i don't
know if it's hairy i take all that back
body is where let's let's get out first
i was about to run
into a lower engine and a report button
comes up and suddenly ksi comes from the
body oh here we go brilliant
ksi ran right up to me in upper engine i
mean harold was there literally five
seconds ago we know without a shot of a
doubt it's not us carl we could just
start dropping them like flies yeah vote
either me or jj but as long as you vote
him as well
okay well i'm voting for simon then i'm
feeling a jj it's jj
yes yes they go him come on i i know but
we we have we have time
you use logic and we've lost every game
stop using logic
and get him the hell out of here all of
you
yes let's go round one your boy was
hella quiet bro this
is tough now we're going to do two
imposters instead of one so if the
impostors win
they're going to get 20 000 collectively
oh my god let's go imposter again oh my
gosh i'm only ever imposter i hate it
well this time i'm not lying so obvious
it's so obvious you know i need to stack
up on a big brain here
then it's less likely that we die
all right you know what oh
i almost did it okay me and jimmy vick's
the big brain
there's call you kill me we aren't cool
you kill me we are cool
oh you kill me around cool you mean we
aren't cool i don't want to sit here and
watch someone be fair imposter
there's no one here what the hell
everyone's here who's on the other one
is everyone just sticking together
there's like 19 people there that's
almost a problem though because it's
almost too many people
i did both i did both o2s trying to do
it as well
okay vic star i'm putting all of my
faith into you paul and tyler make it
down this way to me
here i'm gonna call the emergency
meeting again everyone's good side
oh please hello i have no reason for
calling honestly i thought someone would
be dead so you can skip they've got no
kills
one's got to be harry then what do you
mean one's gotta be me why'd one copy me
harry you run around the map going what
do i do
i don't know what to do nobody can vouch
for anything nobody got a kill
i was literally just curious if someone
died no one did just yeah sorry my bad
i feel like if i kill carl my chance of
winning goes up a lot
don't even don't kill me even don't kill
me even with boys we're boys don't touch
me
oh it might be jimmy he stopped depresso
too
that is big sauce everyone's just
sticking together man there's nothing to
do
i hate it they can't stack like this
hello simon simon don't do it
i just saw toby over here why
oh what the [ __ ] all right here i can
vouch for carl
me and carl was together the entire time
same with it okay i will say 100 vouch
on both of them for this kill for this
kill
but sus on jimmy and i'm not gonna say
why yet
well now i'm starting to get so see you
somebody's trying to big brain right now
jj i saw you stood on the ot fix thing
and you were there for an awful amount
of time what do you mean i just did my
task
ksi does get defensive when he's
impossible oh defensive wow
uh defensive story breaking there was a
knot there was a diamond in the chute
bro bro
the don wrote notes on you no no no no
can we pause
no no can we pull it's a wrap ah bro
ethan and josh
quickly vote for me i voted to skip jj i
don't think it's ksi it had to be an
event kill
if even vote for me i swear to god i
swear to god
so we know one of them is mini minter
but who is the other one i'll go with
chandler and carl
trust these boys i'm gonna die and i
i'm gonna die i [ __ ] do it all right
we got away with it it can't be simon
unless he goes on a killing rampage
simon comes out here it's him
no oh no no no no no
okay i think it's vic why why carl where
yeah
hold on where did you guys separate cars
i lost sight of him at the top of
storage
whoa that's very sustained and why am i
sausage because you were with
him up there this is a second report
that chandler's done then i think it's
you and vic
i'm starting to think carl and vic are
playing us a little bit
okay vic star please finish your tasks
and then do a dance and then i'll do
mine
jimmy stay with me i can't trust anyone
i can't trust anyone stay with me jimmy
minnie mitter stop being stupid everyone
is just next to each other
okay three two
one many minutes
go down go down find the bodies there's
a double kill come on okay perfect
it's a minimeter and jimmy how dumb was
that
yes i'm not losing any money yes
come on boys save the money carl and vic
are playing you ethan that's all i'm
saying
oh yeah okay all right
i thought we agreed you just can't sit
butt buddies all game we could have just
not played the game i could have told
you
no one split up i split up and that's
why i died
thank you everybody for watching
subscribe to sidemen
and we'll see you in whatever they're
doing next